hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast mail management recent
literature on how to reduce aggression
and male mice presented by one of our
keynote presenters briana Gaskell she is
an assistant professor of animal welfare
and the college of veterinary medicine
and part of the Center for Animal
Welfare science at Purdue University I'm
Marjorie torres of labyrinth and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would select
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen will answer
there's many of your questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom or
center of your screen or use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom or
center of your screen and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Fiona
Gasca I will now turn the presentation
over to her all right thank you so much
and welcome to everyone who is attending
this session on Mouse aggression I just
like to say that I was asked to give
this presentation due to a recent
publication in the relaunch of
laboratory animal and lab animal where
we myself and colleagues looked at
several different ways in order to
modulate aggression in mice and so I was
very happy to talk about that
it I wanted to spend a little time
talking a little bit about social
behavior and mice as well so we'll talk
about both of these throughout feet
throughout the presentation but before
we get started I want to introduce you
to the mean team so the work that I will
be presenting later on in this
presentation is the results of lots of
conversations and collaborations and
ideas and a lot of nerdy fun between
myself dr. Joseph Garner who's at
standard for university as well as
Kathleen Pritchett Corning at Harvard
University and so this is some of the
results of some of the work that we've
done together so by far not something
that I'm doing all in isolation here so
the first thing that we really need to
talk about is social behavior in mice in
particular or across various species of
animals so we can look at this
in the idea that social behavior is not
your social you're not social it's
really kind of a spectrum and if we look
at types of animals and the types of
social behaviors that they act in we can
start off by looking at animals that
really do not interact socially much at
all and so these are solitary groups of
animals and a very good example of this
is the Bengal tiger that you can see an
image here now as we move more to groups
that are slightly more social in terms
of the spectrum we have types of
aggregations of animals now this is
where animals gather around a resource
but really there's not a lot of social
interaction and so an example of this
would be fruit flies coming to a
resource to eat food and so they're
gathering together but really not
interacting socially next we have
schools now these types of groups of
animals come together really for some
type of mutual benefit now for this
particular example something like
predator avoidance is a really good
example of why of the type of benefit
these animals might receive by coming
together in these large groups but
there's no relationships here
moving on down the line we have pax
prides and troops of animals now these
animals come together and interact for a
very long period of time there's social
relationships certain animals within the
groups actually have certain roles or
tasks to do within the group and
actually a survival can be very
difficult without these group members
now the thing that's interesting about
this type of animal and social behavior
is that oftentimes reproduction and the
ability to reproduce depends on the
animal social status so those animals
who may be higher up in the in the wolf
pack are more likely to do the breeding
now the last type of social interactions
and relationships that animals might
engage in our colonies or eusocial
societies like bees now these animals
come together in very very large related
groups of animals and in fact there are
some animals that don't ever reproduce
at all such as the worker bee so when we
look at these in terms of the types of
behaviors that they're engaging in in
these different types of species across
this social spectrum we see that the
bottom three or the three furthest to
the left really engage more in social
interactions this is where they're
exchanging social stimuli and responses
such as mating which is not really
something as social as social
relationships which is what we see in
colonies as well as packs now these
relationships individuals recognize each
other and interact consistently over a
significant amount of time and
oftentimes can recognize specific
individuals this could be some type of
parental behavior for those types of
animals now when we look at competition
we tend to see these animals that are
not very social having to compete with
one another for resources a lot more
than we see and the animals that are
engaging in relationships however those
that do
have these true social relationships
seems to have a lot more cooperation
between one another as well as overall
support from those other members of the
group so we can see that in how these
different animals interact differently
in different social ways and so this
really leaves the question where do mice
actually fit into this spectrum well
hopefully we can look at this a little
bit further and delve into some of the
social behaviors of mice and figure out
where they might fit so the most social
structure is really quite complex so for
the most part mice live in 'lose loose
kin kin groups called Dean's where it's
one male one to two breeding females and
those are usually sisters sub-adults as
well as pups within the nest now one
male owns a territory but the other
adults including females will actually
defend this territory quite viciously
and in fact if you've never had the
opportunity to read this book that's
featured in an upper right hand corner
my cell over by Peter Croft it's a
fantastic it's a fantastic read if
you're interested in learning more about
mice and how they interact in the wild
now Krug draft actually talks about the
most vicious aggressive behaviors he
ever witnessed in this observations
hundreds of observations was actually
from a female who was defending the her
young and her nest but we also do see
bachelor groups develop at least this is
what was described in crown crafts book
and we see these male groups kind of
come together in this no-man's land as
you can see in the the image here the
box labeled B these squares are actually
nest boxes and if you notice there's no
dotted line around this particular box
that's because these animals are not
defending any type of territory so the
others that you can see that are
surrounded by the grey
circles and dotted lines those are clear
dividing lines of an animals of a male's
territory so we definitely see that
these bachelor groups do come together
however crowd craft often talked about
them in terms of being decrepid and
sickly-looking and so they probably were
not of the highest fitness now in terms
of how crowd craft was able to really
depict those territories and he often
talked about if he could draw a line on
the ground he could very easily identify
exactly where those territories started
and stopped well this is probably
because those mice had been using
territorial markings in order to kind of
establish the boundaries of that
territory so mice use urinary cues for
navigation as well as edge detection and
they provide a lot of information to to
others in the area so it has an idea
they pass on information about identity
age sex dominance and even health status
and as you can see in the image here
these urinary cues actually even
fluoresce in the UV and you can actually
see the visual distinction such as this
one highlighted here on the left this is
actually the scent marking of a dominant
Mouse that has just been challenged and
so you can see he's really increased the
scent marking around the peripheral of
this territory which just happens to be
a cage and if you compare that to the
mouse on the right who is simply cooling
his urine in the corners of the cage is
making no attempt to show that
peripheral marking of any type of
territory so even visually these
markings are quite distinct an odor can
be really important not only in
conveying information like I said about
sex age reproductive status but it also
helps it also triggers some of these
aggressive interactions so these set
marks
contain urinary pheromones and
aggression promoting camo
now these are used to determine
essentially the maleness of rivals and
those are deposited in those territorial
peripheral marks that I just showed you
now on the flip side we find that other
pheromones or odors seem to help reduce
aggression so the transferring of
nesting material at caged change has
been the only thing that's been found to
truly reduce aggression beyond just
placing an animal in an outer free
environment so such as a clean cage
that's not doesn't have odor from other
animals so this is most likely due to
the fact that nests are often kept clear
of urine and feces so they don't have
these a little babies aggression
components within them now we're not
entirely sure what those pheromones are
but it's been theorized that these are
scents from the plant our glands that
helps with individual recognition
however this has not really been
empirically tested as of yet so animals
engage in lots of different types of
behaviors and some of them can be
positive and some of them can be
negative and so I want to show you a
couple different types of negative
interactions or aggression between mice
and the first of which is called
mediated aggression and essentially
these are aggressive interactions that
are actually what we would consider good
aggression and what I mean by that is
that they're helping to stabilize the
dominance hierarchy and that the animals
are properly communicating and giving
appropriate dominant and subordinates
and signals and you should be able to
identify this in the video so if we
could go ahead and play the video
so you can see from that video that
after the submissive posture was given
the aggressive interaction stopped all
together now compare that to escalated
aggression which is the next type of
aggression and this is often what we
when I 10 you talk about aggression or
fighting this is probably more of what
you're thinking about now escalated
aggression is when those dominant and
subordinate signals are not necessarily
given appropriately where an animal does
not properly submit and actually
retaliates and you should be able to see
this in this video as well so if we
could go ahead and play the escalated
aggression video please
so in that video you should have seen
that the animal did not necessarily give
the same submissive posture at least in
the beginning as we saw in the mediated
aggression video and so these types of
interactions lead to really the problem
behavior of aggression which tends to be
wounding and biting and overall injury
just something that we really don't want
to have with in the laboratory or with
our experimental animals now in terms of
what the literature talks about on what
seems to modulate aggression is that and
one of the things are really important
to point out is there's a lot of
research on aggression but most the time
the type of aggression that people are
using within an experimental stunning is
something that's artificial so you might
be using a resident intruder test which
is not necessarily something indicative
of what animals within a typical shoebox
cage would encounter so in terms of
looking at the research that simply
looked at home cage behavior where we
have where we've been looking at
spontaneous aggression and not
necessarily provoked aggression in that
in an experimental setting there's
really not as much to go by however this
particular study by Van Looy doll was
lovely and looking at how group size and
cage size may affect overall aggression
and this was very unique in the fact
that most the time when people were
looking at the amount of space per
animal they're altering the number of
animals within the cage as well as the
size of the cage itself and so we're
never really able to look at how does
group size actually affect aggression
however van Lew did a really lovely job
of controlling for these two factors and
actually found that really cage space
mice don't really care about as much
overall she did find that larger cages
did seem to lead to more aggression but
she also found that in larger groups
those animals had less stable
hierarchies and so she looked at three
different group sizes of mice so groups
of three five and eight and she
we found groups of five or eight has
significantly more wounding than groups
of three it's also been found that
groups that are familiar or related tend
to result in less aggression overall and
this is essentially due to the fact that
you're putting these animals together a
very young age and primarily before
sexual maturity and we tend to see less
aggression overall for territories we
also see that they if you look at this
image you can see how each of these
small little territories each of these
dotted lines seem to be encircling these
squares or rectangles well in crown
crafts studies he used and provided
these nest boxes and he found that mice
almost always set up their territories
around these nest boxes are physical
structures and the animals would utilize
holes choke points and elevated
platforms in order to ambush intruders
that might come investigating into their
territory
however territory size and the degree of
territoriality of the animals actually
seems to depend on environmental factors
as well such as resource allocation and
distribution and that would affect home
range size plus there are other social
interactions or aspects of social
behavior that may alter this as well so
one of the things that we encounter in
in the lab is the provision of igloos or
shelters hard-plastic physical shelters
and a lot of times we see that these are
very popular they're super easy to clean
and it actually looks enriched so we're
providing something to the animals that
makes us feel good about what we're
doing for them however there aren't a
lot of studies that actually support a
provision of this particular device into
Mouse cages and not just because the
animals actually like it because of the
negative interactions that we see after
it's been provided and why would that be
exactly well based on the image that I
just showed you and the fact that mice
are setting up these
territories around physical structures
we're now introducing that physical
structure into the cage for them to set
this up around and the fact that they
find these shelters so highly valued and
defensible that now you've essentially
set up an aggression time bomb within
your cage this was shown by Howerton at
all where they were looking specifically
at home cage escalated aggression so
that rough-and-tumble in Juris
aggression that were really worried
about and so what they did is they
looked at the amount of aggression that
they found within the cage prior to any
type of experimental treatment being
applied and found that they provided
these igloos similar to the one that I
just showed you on this previous slide
the yellow one was the wheel on top that
regardless of whether the wheel was
glued into place or it was freely moving
the implementation of this physical
structure into the cage significantly
increased the amount of escalated
aggression which in turn led to
alterations in the dominance hierarchy
and so they found a negative correlation
that as escalated aggression increased
they saw a reduction in the dominance
hierarchy linearity and so essentially
there was a lot more chaos and the
animals not necessarily knowing where
they fell within this dominance
hierarchy we also find that with
increased aggression and attacks that
animals receive this has a real
implication of the scientific data that
were using utilizing these animals for
so this study done by Barnett Adal in
1996 found another negative correlation
that as animals receive more text so
they're being attacked by another animal
within the cage we saw that when they
were injected with a blunt blood-borne
pathogen they looked at the amount of
antibodies that were produced by those
animals and that if they received more
attacks there they produce less of those
antibodies for those for that particular
parasite in addition they looked at
Paris
clearance so the number of urethra sites
that were still infected over the course
of the experiment and again they found
this interaction where when animals
received more of those attacks they had
more of those infected urethra sites
still within their body so these animals
were having a difficult time or had an
immune suppression in that they were not
able to clear those particular pathogens
but environment as I mentioned can also
have a huge impact on the overall amount
of aggression so in the wild or in the
lab mice are actually pretty cold so
their lower critical temperature is
right around 30 degrees Celsius which is
about 86 degrees Fahrenheit however we
house them in this range that as you can
see has an increased overall metabolic
rate so mice are utilizing a lot of
energy in order to just maintain a
constant body core temperature however
we found that animals held within this
range have overall at least in the lower
parts of this of the guide recommended
range they have generally lower
aggression rates or aggression scores
based on this one particular study but
as you increase the temperatures even
within the recommended range you see
increases in overall aggression so this
is not something that we want to utilize
and most likely the cold causes the
animals to huddle huddle together more
likely which seems to increase social
compatibility and lower cohesion and so
that's why it may have been way back
when when we first started keeping mice
and laboratories somebody noticed that
animals were less aggressive they had
less animals injured or died this I'm
not really sure but it's possible that
this was something that somebody just
noticed and we've taken on so let's get
into the science that I want to present
and so I talked about the main team
working together and us thinking about
some of these things and
ever the three of us would go out and
give a talk about Mouse behavior it was
always one of the first questions we
received my mice are killing each other
what do I do and so we started thinking
about all of this information about what
seems to modulate Mouse aggression in
the wild and we started thinking about
okay well how could we maybe manipulate
this well we thought at least we could
do it in one of two in two ways either
at the end-user so those who are
purchasing the animals for some type of
scientific research or perhaps the
breeders could help with this as well so
those who are producing the animals that
are going to be used for scientific
research so how could the animals be
managed differently before we ship them
or how do particular genetics or
environmental differences between
breeders potentially influence
alterations in overall aggression and so
at the time when we did this work Kate
and myself we're working at Charles
River and had access to some animals for
some of this research so we first
started asking questions all right well
what could end-users do look at these
pis or laboratory animal technicians or
managers do to try to really mitigate
aggression overall well the pis could
potentially utilize more females however
this is a problem with a lot of the
recents especially here in the United
States
NIH directives basically indicating that
both sexes need to be used which makes a
lot of sense
so that we can look at sex differences
between the drugs or whatever we're
testing on the animals we could order
younger animals but a lot of times we
get a lot of feedback that I don't have
the space or money in order to just
house the animals and my facility for X
number X amount of time before they
actually start on the study they could
buy different mice so there's definitely
some genetic components associated with
overall impression in that some strains
are definitely more aggressive than
others for instance FB bees are
considered very aggressive mice or even
though most people have a lot of black
six
is actually comparatively they fall
somewhere between the moderate to low
ends of overall aggression well maybe we
could actually house them a certain way
maybe we could provide them with various
types of enrichment in order to try to
reduce some of this aggression so that's
really where we decided to go with this
particular study so a little basics of
the design we looked at just aggression
and c57 black 6 NZRL mice and we
provided one of four enrichment
provisions so we had a control group
where the animals only receive the Aspen
bedding that everyone else received at
the same amount we provided them with a
read physical Hut which is very commonly
used or provided them with sunflower
seeds now we heard a lot of anecdotal
information that people were attempting
to mitigate aggression by providing
sunflower seeds at caged change or when
they're initially housing the animals
together and that by providing the
sunflower seeds in the bedding the
animals were foraging and distracted
from potentially a group fighting with
one another and then the last thing that
we thought about was nesting material
obviously there'd been this previous
study done by van Lew that showed that
overall transfer of nesting material and
nesting material in general would reduce
overall aggression now one of the things
we were worried about in this particular
study is that oftentimes people transfer
huts week to week and maybe don't
necessarily wash them or put them
through the cage wash on a weekly basis
and sunflower seeds not only would be
the benefit of eating the seed but also
the foraging associated with it and
potentially nesting material would be
transfer as well and so we were worried
about these enrichments not necessarily
being exactly the same so one of the
things that van Lou did not necessarily
look at was the presence of nesting
material itself without necessarily that
transfer does that seem to reduce
aggression by itself so what we did in
order to try to control for all of these
slightly different things every week
animals got a completely clean new cage
and bedding we didn't just dump them
animals got an entire bottom and top
that were fresh and had never been used
by animals before the animals received a
fresh cut every week and that when we
provided the 50 grams of sunflower seeds
they were sprinkled within the feeder
so that the animals didn't necessarily
get that added enrichment of overall
foraging and then lastly mice were
provided with fresh 8 grams of nesting
material crinkle paper nesting material
every week so we did these in
conjunction with another particular
experimental variable which was sent we
had been hearing a lot of people
thinking that they could potentially
reduce overall aggression by providing
some some odors such as lavender which
at least in in humans and in some other
animals has shown to have a calming
effect so we used a lavender essential
oil and wiped it with a q-tip on the
edge of the cage and then as our
controls we wiped water on the control
on the side of the cage the animals
arrived at approximately 7 to 8 weeks of
age and we had five animals per cage
that were randomly allocated from their
shipping boxes into that particular
enrichment and scent combination now how
did we measure aggression well actually
we decided that we wanted to measure the
overall results so we weren't as
interested in all of these small little
behavioral interactions but what was the
end result so we're more worried about
the wounding that all of this aggression
and most likely escalated aggression
resulted in so what we did is we
developed this Pelt aggression lesion
scale which we fondly called pals and it
was based on a scoring system of zero to
four looking at wounds or discoloration
all the way up to full thickness wounds
and potentially and
hi early absent and techie meant in some
of these extremely aggressive animals
and what we did was after euthanasia the
animals were pelted and we put relayed
virtually this three by three grid on
top of the sub judice of the pelt and
this was based off of the human rule of
nines which essentially allocates equal
amounts of surface area to various areas
of the body and so what we would do is
we scored from zero to four
each of these nine regions and also
added in and weighted based on the
percentage of that particular grid
region that could actually be read so
for instance for the top right grid
that's the right shoulder you see that
some of it is actually blocked off with
fur and so that particular region would
probably only get a weight of 75% of
that grid being accurately read and this
particular measure was validated and
actually found to be very sensitive in
that it can distinguish between actual
aggressive wounding and wounding
associated from ulcerative dermatitis
and so we were really excited to see
that this could distinguish the
difference between those two so in terms
of our overall results from this
particular study nicely we found that
with increasing pals scores we saw
increasing severity so that was really
good to see that our measure was
actually measuring what we thought and
that we found that overall surprisingly
enrichments in general did not alter Pal
scores however we did find that controls
and sunflower seeds had slightly higher
scores but that was not significantly
different from huts or nesting material
which was a little surprising to us
because based on the literature that I
just showed you about implementing
physical structures this should have
increased escalated aggression but
apparently it wasn't enough to increase
powell scores altogether however we did
see some differences in
facing average body weight with
increasing pals though this definitely
could be the fact that as animals are
spending more time in the cage they're
getting heavier and there's more time
for them to receive some of these
injuries so this is something that we're
wanting to look into a little bit
further but the results that I think we
were all a little surprised with was
actually the scent being the only thing
in this particular study that we found
real significant differences based on
our main treatments and basically we
found that lavender increased the
weighted pals score so these animals had
more injury than the animals did that
just received the water so this was
quite surprising to us seeing is how
lavender is supposed to be calming and
we were hoping it might reduce
aggression or do nothing at all but
oddly enough we found that lavender
increased overall Pal scores so whatever
you do do not try to provide any type of
aromatherapy specifically lavender
aromatherapy to your animals without
proper examination so next we moved on
and at about the time we were running
this particular study at Charles River
our colleague Joe was running a study
over in over at Stanford and he was
looking at some of those idiosyncratic
be aggressive behaviors that I showed
you and so she sent us this video and we
were all shocked simply due to the
interactions that I showed you earlier
are about different communication cues
that the animals have to identify
dominance and subordinates so in this
particular video one of the things that
I want you to notice is that one
particular animal is definitely showing
a lot of dominance related behavior or
aggressive related behaviors and the
other animals in the cage appear to be
providing the appropriate social cues to
stop that particular aggressive
interaction
however the dominant doesn't seem to
react the same way and then essentially
it becomes extremely chaotic and we
start to see behaviors
we would not necessarily expect so if we
could go ahead and play the aggression
video please
you
so you probably saw in that video the
animals doing lots of submission
submissive postures but those negative
interactions really not stopping now the
thing that was just shocking to us so
those are really appropriate cues the
animals should have been giving granted
the dominant was not responding
appropriately was when those animals
that were giving those upright
subordinates submissive postures a few
minutes after they went back into their
corners and started tail rattling tail
rattling is a territorial behavior and
subordinates don't tail rattle or at
least it's very unlikely it's not the
appropriate settings for them to
potentially be doing those tail rattling
and as we notice they tail rattled in
the corners and then the dominant came
back over and then they submitted again
they gave those submissive postures and
so it really appeared that these animals
were not speaking the same language they
were not communicating the way that
they're supposed to and so we really
started thinking about this and how and
other animals dogs in particular that if
you take them away from their litter
mates and their mother too early an age
they don't really ever learn how to
respond appropriately like a dog and so
we started wondering if there was a
sensitive period in mice and that
actually maybe we're taking them away
from taking them weaning them too early
where they're not necessarily learning
these appropriate dominant and
subordinate hues so we went back to the
literature and we found that Curley at
all in 2009
looked at weaning animals at two
different ages at 21 days or in at 28
days and found that essentially the
animals that were weaned
Peter seems to have longer durations of
social interactions which we thought was
really interesting and so whether that
actually indicates social confidence
that's a different question but at least
they're engaging they seem to engage
more in social interactions so we kept
thinking about weaning and how it's
really a gradual process and that about
10 to 17 days of age might start eating
solid foods we definitely see a
reduction in nursing behavior around 21
days which is probably why we wean them
as well as the point where there's a new
litter probably coming into the cage but
we also see that at least in the wild
mice tend to remain in the natal nest up
until sexual maturity so there's lots of
opportunities for them to engage in
these different types of behaviors and
then we notice that in the same paper by
Curley at all that they were talking
about this pup mounting behavior and it
was seen around the time of weaning and
they described it specifically for
females because this was a Lisa cage of
pups and a female and there were no
males in the cage so I thought perhaps
it was just a way to keep the pups from
nursing but about the same time I was
reviewing I was working on another
project where I was viewing a lot of
reproductive behavior and watching a lot
of breeding cage behavior and I started
seeing these same behaviors however I
saw the male doing them as well so in
this particular video you'll actually
see the female kind of passed out in the
left-hand corner of the cage and on the
right hand side you'll see the male
attempting to mount a few pups so if
we'll go ahead and play that video
so you saw that male grooming as well as
mounting that pup at the same time and
we actually see mounting behaviors and
females as some type of dominance as
well and so in Curly's paper they
actually found that around the days when
those animals were going to be weaned
and they also Weems these groups of
animals at different ages in a previous
generation that they saw an increase of
those mounting behaviors right around
the points when those animals had
previously been weaned so if you were
weaned at 21 days you had your own
litter you started doing more of that
pop mounting at 21 days but if you were
weaned at 28 days and then had your own
litter you tended to show an increase of
those mounting behaviors a little bit
later so - about 24 days and another
slight increase right around 28 and so
we started really thinking about it well
maybe there's something here maybe these
animals are being taken away too early
and that just at the point where we're
separating them that's the point where
they're starting to learn these dominant
and subordinate cues so we look a little
bit further into the literature and in
one particular study by kick Suey at all
they found that animals that were weaned
at different days of age so 14 days or
21 days that they had significant
differences in a number of wounds that
those animals received so animals at 14
days has significantly more wounds than
those that were weaned
at 21 days now I will put out this
particular caveat that this was a
separation induced aggression paradigm
where the animals were separated for I
believe four to four weeks and then
brought back together for a week and so
they looked at the number of wounds
those animals received so not exactly
the situation that we're thinking about
about just in-home cage behavior but we
also see that weaning age seems to lead
to abnormal behavior development as well
so verbal and staff assure in 1997 found
that pups that were weaned at 17 days of
age had to had pretty high levels of
wire nine
gnawing stereo Tippy's aperi a
particular type of abnormal behavior
however even animals that were weaned at
more of a typical age show about 20 days
if they were in the lower parts of the
average weaning weight they had fairly
similar amounts of wire 9 stereo Tippy's
but if you were in the upper average of
that particular letter you had
significantly lower so it might be
something to do with maybe these animals
are not fully are not fully developed in
the way that they should be so we took
this knowledge and we decided to take it
back to to the breeder and what we could
change well we could potentially alter
the way animals are shipped however we
didn't have the opportunity to examine
that we could potentially look at the
age at which the animals are weaned
which based on some of this previous
literature seems to indicate um and
altered their overall behavior or maybe
what we could do is we could look at how
the animals were handled so at the time
at Charles River within their breeding
facility the animals were weighed Andry
sorted on a weekly basis and so these
animals were sorted and resource old and
this could be even multiple times but
maybe instead of doing that what if we
held the animals and stable groups if
that would affect the overall aggression
so what we did is we applied two
different treatments again to our same
c57 black 6 mice and the first treatment
was weaning age we weaned animals at 14
21 or 28 days of age and this was
applied in a factorial design with two
different mixing treatments the first
was the standard quo of weakly mixing
based on weight and the second was due
to stable weaning groups so once they
were weaned even though there might be a
few letters within this big stock cage
they were not constantly mixed and
remixed they stayed with those group of
animals again at about seven to eight
weeks we had the animals shipped to us
and we again allocated five animals per
cage in in a Vives
disposable caging
and what we found was that we did find a
significant difference in our overall
Pal score based on weaning age however
it was the complete opposite of what we
expected in that we expected that the 14
day old 14 day of age weaned pups would
be more aggressive or would have more
wounding but in fact we found they had
the least and that the animals that had
the later weaning the 28 day old they
seemed to have the overall higher Pal
scores or overall wounding now we didn't
find any significant differences due to
mixing or stable groups in this
particular study so with some of this
data we went back and we were thinking
about well maybe not all black sticks
are created the same weed again heard a
lot of different anecdotal evidence that
pee I swore that they would only buy a
particular type of black six miles from
one particular vendor so we decided to
actually evaluate that under the same
conditions so what we did is we bought
animals black 6 c57 black 6 mice of
different sub strains so animals from
Jax Charles River mice Harlan which is
now in Vigo as well as Taconic and
compared these animals in their overall
wounding and wounding rate at about the
same time and ultimately found that we
didn't have any significant differences
in overall Pal scores between these sub
strains so at least in the conditions
that we were housing them in it didn't
seem to alter their overall wounding
rate however with this particular study
we had just received a tail tattoo
machine and we're really eager to try it
out and so we had run these other
previous two studies with animals simply
being ear snips or ear marked ear
notched and so instead of completely
switching our method of of marking
animals we decided to at least of all of
these sub strains 5 animal 5 cages
received the traditional ear notch and 5
of the cages received the tail tattoo
and of course again this is not what we
expected
it whatsoever and we found that overall
the marking method in this particular
experiment was more influential on
overall wounding than the sub strain and
that animals what the ear slice had
significantly higher weighted Pal scores
than those that received the tail tattoo
which again was something that was
completely surprising to us and not
something that we expected at all so
with all of this data I'm sure you're
probably sitting there thinking all
right well you found things that were
completely opposite I still have to
figure out what to do with my mice so if
you have animals that may be hanging out
in your lab for an extended period of
time
maybe housing those males with over
overreact amaya see males may be a
solution they've been a few publications
showing that overreact to Mai's females
specifically most likely of the same
strain are going to be actually really
good partners for those animals
providing the social interaction without
necessarily the negative ramifications
of social interaction and in fact the
study by spanning it all at the bottom
here showed that those animals that were
housed with that overreact amazed female
had overall lower heart rates than the
individuals that were housed by
themselves so this might be an option
and that even in the study done by Ed it
woloson she found that you could pair
and repair those overreact to Mai's
females even with very young males and
they were still very successful so this
might be a good solution so overall as
some conclusions that I will leave you
with is that overall social interaction
is essential for social species and
definitely I think we've shown that mice
fall somewhere within the middle of that
spectrum of social interactions and
potentially social relationships seeing
as how they may have multiple
generations overlap with in one
particular Dean and so combating
aggression is still a really major
challenge and we're still working to try
to figure out how to reduce overall
rates of aggression in
our vivarium but some of the work that
van Lew did has some really good and
tips on how to actually reduce this and
so the first of which was to try and
house males in small stable groups at a
young age to transfer nesting material
during cage cleaning to keep
disturbances at a minimum and actually
she recommended trying to combine
procedures such as cage cleaning with
some type of manipulation perhaps an
injection and actually I found this to
be very successful with CD ones in a
toxicology project that I've worked on
making sure that when you provide
enrichments you provide the right amount
so that they can't be guarded and that
nesting material is probably better than
rigid Hut's that can easily be protected
and territory set up around and last
definitely be conscious of the marking
method you're using because you may be
modulating overall aggression simply by
identifying that type the mouse from one
and another and with that I'd like to
thank my aggression collaborators my
mean team here and point you to an
overall pretty quick and dirty review
that I wrote for the enrichment record
in the winter of 2014 that might provide
you with some good resources as well as
the general overview of oppression and I
believe that still readily available via
the web so with that I'm happy to take
any questions that might house thank you
dr. briana Gaskell for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for let's get started our
first question is what is better for my
male mouse is welfare individual housing
or social housing so this is something
that a lot of us are debating
so you're potentially weighing one
welfare issue for another so individual
housing the literature shows
ubiquitously that isolation can be can
have some very negative implications for
Mouse welfare alteration of physiology
lower brain-derived neurotropic factors
increased quarters quarter cost drones
of stress hormones and this is something
that actually was recently debated
question quite nicely in a study or a
review by Kapil at all in 2017 in the
journal animals and actually they were
debating whether the welfare is
beneficial in one versus the other
and essentially one of the results that
they came out with is that for some of
these very aggressive strains so such as
SV bees which we know are extremely
aggressive that overall it might be
overall more beneficial to house those
males by themselves potentially
providing some type of overreacted eyes
dream L might be an option but just the
risk of the injury and wounding and pain
and potential suffering that those
animals are very likely to encounter we
they believe that that's offset the
welfare implications negative welfare
implications from isolation housing so
overall it probably depends on your
facility what kind of prevalence of
overall aggression you have but
definitely I would encourage you to
attempt to utilize some of these tips
that I showed on the conclusion slide um
to try to figure out how you might be
able to mitigate mitigate aggression but
of course every single facility is
slightly different and you have to make
the best decision possible thank you for
that answer our next question is what
should I do if one of my PI senses on
finding lis housing they're male mice
but the justification is not very
credible basically this is probably more
of something that would be addressed by
the aya cook at that particular
institution
and it's up to the I cook to determine
whether their justification is credible
or not however it doesn't mean that you
don't have an opportunity to educate
that particular pie you can definitely
present them with literature that shows
that isolation housing of their animals
could potentially alter the data that
they're hoping to get from them so for
instance a lot of the current literature
is showing that isolation increases
anxiety and depression behaviors and
typical tests such as the open field the
plus maze are even sucrose consumption
and that again you're seeing increases
in overall stress and stress can have so
many effects on the body and so making
sure that your pie is aware of what
these two different housing types may
imply in terms of their data quality and
so it could be that maybe they do have a
really aggressive strain so it may be
the better option to singly house those
animals because the likelihood of having
to separate them is going to be
significantly higher so again this is
probably a question best left up to the
I cook and making sure that they're
doing their job to make sure that there
is a strong scientific reason for singly
housing these animals but it doesn't
mean that you can't provide some
peer-reviewed literature for that P I to
come to a decision based on all of the
information possible hey we have time
for one more question
a last question is can I transfer dirty
bedding you're not do that so um I have
heard instances where people have had
success with this but I would caution
you quite strongly about not doing this
um the reason being that so I showed you
those images of the scent marks being
distributed around the perimeter of the
cage most likely because that's what the
Domenic sees is its territory and then
you saw the subordinates that we're
pooling their urine in the corners of
those cages now how do you know
that you are absolutely picking up the
scent marks of that dominant Mouse and
putting it in the cage into the clean
cage or stirring it around basically
probably what's happening is if you do
sprinkle that dirty bedding around in
the cage it's entirely likely that
you're transferring some of those
subordinate scents as well and they get
into this new cage and the Damas like
hey man I thought we've got this all
figured out and he was like I swear I
didn't do it but it's possible that
you're transferring the wrong smells and
so that's why we generally recommend do
not transfer any type of dirty bedding
and then if you're going to transfer
anything at all
transfer the nesting material as long as
it's clean and fluffy so with highly
aggressive cages we definitely see a
nest building falter and actually the
nesting material just ends up being
scattered throughout the throughout the
the cage and so it's very difficult to
find any clean nesting material I would
tell you not to transfer that dirty
greasy nesting material that doesn't
come from a concentrated nest site
that's clean and fluffy because you
again may be transferring some of those
urinary pheromones or aggression
aggression aggressive stimulating
chemicals in the urine from the bedding
and or dirty nesting materials so just
make sure that the nesting material is
clean and fluffy and that you don't see
any types of your interfaces present
with our nest and that that's what you
should transfer I would like to once
again thank dr. Briana and Gaskell for
her for her presentation I would also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational web cast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
the today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May of
2018 you will receive an email from
labyrinth letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
laughs event that's all for now thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon goodbye